I went in Tucson Nebraska a few days ago
and I was blown away by the movie and by
your performance I think really and
really excited for you because you've
been such a good friend to us over the
years
you got nominated for an Independent
Spirit Award for better this is your
first dramatic role is that right yeah I
mean I have done a lot of comedies that
have not gotten any laughs so I feel
like it's kind of a transitioned into it
in that way so now you can call those
earlier dramatic they're all their
dramatic parts this is my first official
technical drama now there's suspicion or
maybe even it must have crossed your
mind there you what have you got a an
Oscar nomination either kind of person
who's superstitious
I am very I am superstitious like meme
even mentioning it bothers you or you're
just in general superstitious oh I'm
just in general superstitious I am a
little OCD and that OCD mixed with
superstition makes the superstition set
even more okay right so well give me an
example like what are your sister
positions about like I have a pair of
socks that I always wear on airplane
through these Los Angeles Clippers socks
and I've never been in a plane crash so
I will never stop wearing them until my
first crash then I'll switch to Y LA
Clippers socks what made you try I'm a
huge fan of the Clippers and they're
just really soft socks they're just
amazing socks okay yeah are you
superstitious in general I bet I love it
Beckett said people are laughing for
softer book yes
better than hard ones yeah there there's
another this one's kind of gross but
there's another weird superstition
related to the Clippers I went to a
Clippers game with my friend Matt rice
and it's I get nervous during the game
so at some point I always bite my
fingernails and I took one of my fans
out and I put it on Matt's sweater
that's the kind of thing I do as a
friend and he is a friend of mine so
he'll accept it and he went up to me and
he took it off his sweater and he put it
in his mouth and right then
the Clippers threw up this crazy 3-point
shot that made it in right so as if we
were just going oh my god that must be
the combination of wills fingernails and
Matt's saliva or Matt's mouth is a lucky
thing so we go to we go to halftime come
back the Clippers are now down by quite
a bit so we all said oh well what you
know why don't we bite off another
fingernail and put it in Matt's mouth I
did it and the Clippers stormed back and
won the game Wow
really so you're and you're attributing
this to him eating not eating but just
holding in his mouth eat it he's not an
animal yeah so anyway several other
weird coincidences happened involving
luck with my fingernails in his mouth
and then eventually he there was there
was this well never Ronnie it's a long
story but eventually a couple couple
weeks later he he was gonna he proposed
to Marissa who was now his wife and so
for like the next year I shoot off my
fingernails and saved it in a baggie to
present it to him on his wedding day and
then I I totally forgot to give him the
the bag so I have this bag of chewed up
fingernails in my drawer now yeah yeah
it's like you're a serial killer you
know
it's very gross